hello and welcome to in two minutes the
show that says hey don't worry about it
we know you're busy we'll get you those
cliff notes and work to your schedule
for the last week or so I've been
heading off to the fantasy land of
Thetas to head up an inquisition I feel
like I'm a little under qualified but
there is a giant hole in the sky with
demons pouring out of it so I guess
someone's got to do something it has
been quite a while since I last played
Dragon Age Origins and Dragon Age 2 so I
was having a little trouble remembering
everyone was when I went through the
Dragon Age keep to set up my world state
for Inquisition well this happened who
are you oh my god I don't remember this
at all
i romanced knew the outcome of Dragon
Age is utterly dependent on the choices
that you as the player make so doing a
story so far doesn't really make sense
cuz it's gonna be different for everyone
so how's about a refresher on some of
the races and factions in Vedas much
better let's enroll in some Dragon Age
101 two minutes let's go starting with
the Chantry the dominant religious
organization in Thetis they follow the
words of the Prophet andris day who
speaks on behalf of God like entity the
maker their leader the divine rules out
of the affluent region of olay they have
a lot of power for example they've
pretty much control all of the mages in
Vedas they govern Hogwarts I mean the
circle of magi a group of mandatory
training academies / prisons the kids
study until they undertake their Oh W
else I mean harrowing to become full
circle members those who chickened out
basically get lobotomized and become
tranquil which is just as dark as it
sounds but it's because weak mages are
easily possessed by demons and then
they're called abominations not all
majors are kept under lock and key the
wealthy tevinter imperium region is
ruled by a gang of powerful Gandalf's
there's also the keeper's clan leaders
of the nomadic dalish elves fair mages
free from Chantry chains just as long as
they stay away from large cities
you know don't make the place of messy
the Templar order is the military branch
of the Chantry charged with keeping
circle majors safe by imprisoning them
but also hunt down free majors known as
apostates using their own special
Templar magic the seekers of truth are V
Chantry Secret Service who protect the
organization by investigating magical
threats and rooting out corruption like
shouty interrogating lady Cassandra from
dragon age to canari aren't just a bunch
of pale grumpy horned giants it's also
the name of followers of the [ __ ] a
religion which anyone can join Levin has
Roth a Qunari warriors who enforced
religious law but also re-educate those
who aren't following the rules then
there's the Grey Wardens
an ancient order of warriors whose sole
job is to slay demon esque baddies the
darkspawn to join you gotta survive the
joining ritual which involves drinking
darkspawn blood amongst other noxious
liquids wardens have the power to invoke
a treaty to get all the factions to make
nice and work together useful in
situations when oh I don't know demons
are falling from the sky
there's the bell classes over and that's
your Quick Start Guide to some of dragon
ages big players in just under two
minutes even I'm not sure how that
happened oh yeah wait because I cut out
all of the story bits so hopefully this
week's episode will help you get back
into that Dragon Age mindset before you
take up arms form your own Inquisition
slay some demons and try to work your
way around the game one romanced
companion at a time I'll be back again
next week with another rundown of
gaming's hottest thing until then you
can catch me on Twitter at Lucy James
games I'll see you next time